hey everybody is Jessie and today we're
going to continue right where we left
off yesterday so I had to work on some
other stuff and I had to fix one problem
with the project that we had worked on
previously that had to do with the JW
player video but I kind of fixed it was
basically a workaround but I'm done with
that and I'm ready to start on this
project yesterday we made some decisions
about it and we're going to use material
UI
as the framework and we use create react
app to get everything started so today
we're just going to go through and try
to build our layout with material UI
I've never used it before I'm familiar
with material design but I'm not
familiar with material UI specifically
so this is kind of going to be a trial
and error learning session today where
you're just going to go through and see
how things work if you're watching on
Instagram this is the the view of me
coding so if you want to see the code
check it out on the free code camp
youtube channel you can watch it live
now or if you have seen the recording
later on this will be the title of the
video is react project day to learning
material UI and that's on the live
coding with Jessie playlist on the free
code camp channel alright so let me get
you take a look at the live chat say
hello to everyone
all right hey everyone cool let's see
some familiar faces and some new people
so if you're new welcome and don't be
afraid to ask questions give advice
definitely open to to
that if you are new this is not really a
tutorial this is just me doing my
everyday work so there are going to be
mistakes it's not rehearsed beforehand
so I guess that's it can be good at
times because we try to work through the
mistake so eventually we usually figure
out the right way to do things
let me know yesterday we had some issues
where my phone was giving interference
with my microphone so let me know if
that happens again and I can move it so
right now I'm trying to manage the phone
streaming at the same time as the
YouTube streaming so if it's too much I
can just cut the the phone stream I
don't have nearly as many people watch
the phone stream alright so just go in
the live chat real quick see everyone
wow the tailor says it's it's night time
it's to 2:00 a.m. Wow Taylor where you
at right now that it's 2:00 a.m. already
Alessandra put the little parenthesis
and the the fire looks like the free
code camp logos that's really cool let's
see white white lightning says hey
Jessie big fan of material design some
interesting how you tackle material UI
cool yeah i'm i really like material
design as well so I'm really hoping
material UI turns out to be awesome
because I'd love to use it
let's see okay I think we can get
started
Oh Sean says Jessie I've had some
problems with the previous react project
okay let me know uh oh Sean send me a
message on Twitter and let me know what
issues you're having or you can open up
an issue on the github repo for that
project so I'd like to know what's going
on with that and see if we can get those
problems fixed Evo says 8 p.m. here in
the Netherlands so perfect time for live
stream cool that's cool I always I don't
really worry that much about what time I
stream because people are watching from
everywhere so it doesn't really matter
what time I stream it's gonna be you
know a different time for everyone so it
would be cool to do it maybe some
morning streams my time just to give
people a chance to watch it who maybe
can never watch it 11:30 p.m. in India
Alan from Michigan seer hey how's it
going
I have heard of react MD I have not used
it the Kevin says how are you not bad
I'm pretty tired got up really early
with the baby this morning so definitely
running on some caffeine I had a double
espresso this morning and right now I'm
drinking some G fuel it's like an energy
drink so hopefully I can do a good job
in this stream I usually get pretty
pumped up when I'm doing the stream and
I don't feel quite as tired unless it's
like a three hour stream then I start to
feel it alright so I'm gonna get started
I'll come back periodically and check
out the live shot and try to answer the
questions I've been having a lot of
people ask a lot of questions in the
live chat so let me know what you all
think but I've been thinking about maybe
have
some sort of moderator in the chat not
really to like tell people what to do
but just to keep track of when people
ask questions so there's some questions
that I probably don't need to answer
like when people ask about like what
what editor I'm using or what the theme
is things like that there are basic
questions or when people come in and say
like hey what are you working on which
those are valid questions especially if
you knew but everybody else in the live
chat could could answer those just as
well as I could so those kind of
questions would be cool to have the
moderator basically categorized the
questions between ones that have a
simple answer that could just be handled
in live chat and the ones that I
probably should answer and then you know
when it's time for me to go back to the
live chat to answer questions then I
would I'd be able to see those somehow
so I'm not sure exactly how it'll work
out maybe there's already something
developed to handle stuff like that and
if you all know about a good way to
handle that let me know and if anybody's
interested in kind of being a moderator
let me know as well I would just say if
you are going to be a moderator make
sure you're somebody who doesn't have a
bad temper and is very patient because I
like to keep everything really positive
no matter what people are saying so I
don't want anybody getting upset at the
the people in the live chat
I don't consider any question to be you
know like too much of a noob question or
anything so anyway so I'm gonna give it
some thought and if you all want to give
some thought and let me know you know
maybe I'll do that we'll see yesterday
was a crazy day we had just a lot of
people in the chat today is still above
average but not quite as crazy so maybe
I won't need it we'll see for right now
I'm gonna start up my Pomodoro timer and
try to you get into our first coding
session oh one more thing this is not an
endorsement just just a helpful
fYI Udacity is having I think like a 50%
off sale right now in their courses so
if you were thinking about doing a
course from Udacity now would probably
be a good time to sign up because there
you know that's a pretty big discount
for their courses so unfortunately I
already signed up for my course about a
month ago so I won't get the discount
but I know I think some of you in the
chat had mentioned that you're
interested in doing some of the courses
like the react course or anything so
it's a good deal right now alright so as
you can see I didn't do literally I did
nothing with this project since
yesterday I didn't even have time to set
this up so I don't even have a link to
this yet because right now there's
nothing in there
so I'm not I'm not gonna worry about the
Trello board I'll kind of have to like
go back and fill in what we've done I am
keeping track of the the time that I've
put into this on a separate spreadsheet
on my other screen so I'm gonna know how
much time I put into things I'll just
have to fill out the Trello board later
on alright so let's get our code up here
let me get things organized how we
probably normally have it let's see I
think I probably want to do kind of a
side by side to minimize that and
I yeah this should work I probably don't
need to see places right now we can get
rid of that and let's get rid of this
side there we go that'll give us plenty
of space
increase the font a bit let me know if
that font is too small and I probably
won't look at the chat for a little
while but if I see it all I'll make it a
bit bigger okay so one thing I noticed
yesterday but I didn't do anything about
is that this doesn't do anything and it
seems like it should right so let's I'm
gonna see what's going on here I think
this is probably one of those things
where that that kind of extra click
thing that we had talked about yesterday
see I don't need that let's go to the
setup and see what they were saying
about okay so this tap event plug-in
this is probably what we need to make
that work so let's bring that in
well these semicolons are freaking me
out a little bit on the last project I
got used to not using the semicolons and
now they're there and I can't take it
they just look I'm just gonna take them
out right now it's been really bothering
that I do we get them all no one more
all right cool
no semicolons I think at some point
we're gonna have to eject create react
app and do some X some stuff with it
because I'd love to have the automatic
formatting like we had when our with our
other project alright so is this I just
want to see if I have to actually
install this if it comes with
it looks like I have to install it so I
mean it's worth a shot
to see if it comes with it first but and
it's
hmm
so I'm wondering it at least this is not
really descriptive in terms of what I to
put this inside of component didn't
mounts I mean would that be maybe I'll
look at these docks might be a bit
better
oh okay so we're saying just initialize
it right there okay
all right let's try it out like I said I
might have to install this it didn't say
on these instructions so there's I guess
the possibility that it'll just work
didn't start up my server so let me
start up my dev server in the console
here let's see where am I
it's just going to use yarn start I did
see somebody left a comment in the video
yesterday about like the latest version
of NPM is actually just as fast as yarn
and it has like the same a similar lock
file so Wow the the error page looks way
different for create react app than it
did for for next that's that's crazy but
anyway for this project at least I'm
gonna stick with yarn since I've already
I'm already using it but I'll have to
look into that and maybe in future
projects I'll I'll just use the newest
version of NPM I just I just saw I just
happened to look over quickly to live
chat and I saw white lightnings comment
about his question his or her question
sorry about why not use semicolons
basically I did use semicolons and then
on the last project everyone watching
the stream kind of convinced me not to
use them and we had like some Auto
formatting going on with we're using
prettier for that and it automatically
removed semicolons so I just got used to
it and now that I got used to it I don't
want to go back it's really nice to not
have to type out that semicolon it seems
to me that if there's not really a
difference between semicolons and not
semicolons then the easier route is
better and easier route being just not
at a semicolon so I mean that works for
me I don't really care if anybody else
use semicolons it's not it doesn't
bother me if they use semicolons but at
least for my projects I think I'm gonna
not use semicolons
anymore so boys that I just want to see
all right so tap event plug-in
so this should be what we need let's go
to our console where do you go now I
moved it to the side sorry yeah this is
it okay
yarn add actually let me make this
bigger
I made this smaller earlier just to give
me more space to work with there we go
so we're gonna add that tap event
plug-in and hopefully everything works
okay there we go
all right let's try to restart
there we go and okay well still nothing
happens we probably needed to install
that anyway so I'm not really worried
about that but I do want to see why I
think I was going down the wrong path
here in terms of trying to find this out
so it looks like it wasn't the type of M
plug-in I think this is the code that we
use let's see what is going on
I need I'm assuming that this is
basically also you know the same
component here so obvious obviously it's
working there yeah this is a react site
let's just see how they did it I'm gonna
check the live chat here in a second too
because I'm sure that some of you are
thinking Jessie what are you doing
here's the simple answer that often
happens you are usually ahead of the
game or at least ahead of me alright so
let's see
what was that who's the name of that app
bar
here we go
it's odd
it's just not really a nap board
component oh well maybe maybe mine
doesn't even have a nap bar component
oh yeah so it looks like maybe it's a
different version for that I don't know
so there's a huge difference I guess
between what's going on with the you
know between my site and this site so
I'm probably not going to be able to use
that for an example so let me check out
the the live chat here
alright let's see I'll screw up a bit
just to see
okay so it looks like you do not add an
event for left button and app bar so if
you click it nothing at okay so I have
to add oh it's actually have to add the
event okay cool good to know thanks
Sebastian and tour I I'm not sure how
would you pronounce that it's it looks
like it's t o re so let me know how you
want me to pronounce that okay you must
add props to the phone okay cool let's
check out I'm gonna move this I guess I
don't need to move this over right now I
don't need to see it so let's check out
what props there we go I feel a little
bit silly now if I would have just
scroll down and read all this I would
have known sometimes it's just more fun
to just try it and see what happens
especially if I'm doing a stream like I
don't want to spend the whole time
reading that would be boring alright so
callback function every touch so alright
cool so I do need to add let's add this
drawer area
cool
how do I get out of the drawer okay so
[Music]
let's put in a drawer and import all
these
all right so I'm not gonna include the
button sexually I probably don't need
this button because I want to make my my
icon the drawer so I just need this
drawer and I guess I'll put this oops
just put this right below the app at bar
and we'll leave it to state open for now
just to see it make sure it's working
and let's see all right I'm not gonna
worry about this for now I just want to
see if it works
oops gonna be property open oh yeah
let's see of course I have to put state
in
and let's leave it open okay cool
nice and all right so now let's go back
to our yeah let's go back to our app bar
and let's see on left icon I'm gonna add
this
this weird per second I kept clicking
and it wasn't doing anything it was odd
so we're gonna want
for now just something simple so let's
say
I'll just copy what they have here save
some typing
okay thanks Patrick Pat Patrick just
paste it in the live chat exactly what
what I need to do here so cool
okay
I see oops what's going on here I expect
it's okay
only this
whoa what is this what did I do
all right whatever happened there it
didn't happen again so I'm cool with
that
okay No
okay thanks I forgot this
yeah all right cool it's always the
worst awesome okay it seems like that's
the hardest part when I do live streams
is you just forget syntax that you type
all the time but for some reason when
it's live your mind just blanks so I
really appreciate it when you all catch
that and uh and let me know what the
syntax is it saves me having to look it
up which I'm fine with going but it does
keep the stream moving along faster when
you all help me out like that so I
really do appreciate it okay so we need
the desired behavior is that if you
click outside of this it will close so
let's let's check on that so I'll
probably need to go back into the drawer
component and let's see
this has got to be any I mean this is
pretty basic functionality so
okay I think I probably forgot to add
something mmm no I guess I didn't
all right this is the one I want I want
to say
so I'm trying to figure out which which
part
which part of this is actually making it
is it the undocked part let's see what
on doctors dot okay so it just brings up
the overlay so that makes sense
hmm that not all right so I'm not seeing
the overlay now what did I do
okay I did not put this in there which
maybe that's what's messing things up No
all right I'm gonna look at the live
chat
oh man you guys saw it Sebastian I see
Sebastian saw it for sure
I added the this these two props I had
it on the wrong component so I did have
open what am I thinking
okay so now this will make a lot more
sense to me hopefully this is what I
need
yeah okay it works cool alright my timer
is up so I'm gonna take a short break to
go to the live chat and check up on what
I missed answer some questions I'm
preparing myself mentally now to see all
of you telling me what I was doing wrong
since I just made a series of silly
mistakes alright so let me scroll up a
bit
no I got 82 viewers now that's that's
nice it's um it's definitely over what
we normally average so probably a lot of
new people and I'm guessing so welcome
thanks for watching and so I'm scrolling
almost all the way back up to the top
Carl says hey Jesse or anyone after
completing the JavaScript section on
free code camp is it safe to try and
jump into react or is there more to do
I'd say go ahead and jump into reacts I
I don't think there's anything wrong
with you know trying it out if it seems
like it's too difficult then maybe you
know go to something else and come back
to it later on but you don't have to be
a JavaScript master to know react and
you'll get better at JavaScript as you
do react because you'll find yourself
using parts of JavaScript that you maybe
didn't use before that was my experience
all right we got people from someone
from the Ivory Coast Ukraine oh man
Philip says I'm feeling you there my son
got up at 5:00 a.m. this morning can't
wait until he is a teen I don't think
I've ever heard anyone say can't wait
till he's a teen usually people hey
Dredd the teenagers but yeah I suppose
teenagers will probably sleep in so I
guess that's something to look forward
to I'll finally get better sleep with my
kids get bigger
now it's Steven as says Steven says I'd
love to see a black screen with green
font much easier for an old guy to watch
I could say if if you all have a really
cool theme you'd like to suggest to me
put it in the comments for this video or
you can message me on Twitter but I'm
using Adam as my code editor so if you
do have a theme for that that you want
to suggest I'll try it out if I if I
like it then you know maybe I'll do that
for the streams I don't think I've
changed my theme for years are the same
same theme so it might be cool to change
it up all right let's see
alright looks like some of you you're
saying that I could use a bot to help
moderate the chat that would be cool
hey Phillip votes for Patrick to be the
moderator hi from Down Under
oh cool so Jack does that mean you're
from Australia because that's cool if
you are from Australia because I've
never had anyone in the live chat say
that they were from Australia and that's
the only like the only continent other
than of course Antarctica that I haven't
had somebody say that they're from so
that's really awesome now I can honestly
tell people that I've had people from
all the habitated continents okay
Stephen said the udacity sail is
actually more than 50% off that's
awesome
also since we're talking about sails
Nordstrom has has sales going on right
now if you need some clothes I needed a
new pair of black dress shoes so I
bought a pair on my lunch break
also anytime I talk about a product or
anything I don't officially endorse or
get paid to talk about anything so this
is all my honest opinion
Stephen says yeah use prettier atom
package oh yeah I haven't thought about
that just using the atom package before
I it was like a like a commit hook to
where every time I committed it would
change everything
use standard J s as well for linting but
I hadn't even thought of just doing it
in atom I can't would like to have it as
part of like the commit hook so that if
people want to do a pull request
everything is the same but I guess until
I checked actually I'm not sure is it do
I need that's probably a good question
let me check this out
do I even need to eject create react app
in order to set that up I thought I did
but now but I'm thinking about it I
don't I really don't think I will
because I don't really need to change
anything with with like web pack so I
think I could just do it so maybe I'll
try not right now but at some point
maybe I'll try to just bring over a lot
of the stuff we use for the last project
for linting and like formatting and try
to use it here all right so my
five-minute timer is up for the chat so
I'm gonna just kind of go through really
really quickly and see if there's
anything super important that I I should
address before I go on
okay so see there are some questions
I'll try to come back to the questions a
little bit later Wow 2:15 a.m. and China
looks like Sierra from 2:15 a.m. and
China Wow so thanks for staying up so
late and watching
Thailand South Way says seeing this is
awesome I'm currently making my tribute
page keep up the good work that's cool
send me send me a message on Twitter I
want to see the the tribute page when
when you're done with it that would be
cool so if you don't mind I'd like to
check that out
Ricardo from Brazil says your live
streams are great awesome thank you -
best of hardstyle from Portugal
I enjoy some some hardstyle occasionally
ok cool
let's get back to work if by the way if
you ask a question in the chat and
you're not able to stick around until I
go through it later on you can just send
it to me on Twitter or put it in the
comments for this video and then I will
get to it later on when I can because I
realize yeah sometimes the streams go
really long so it might be an hour or
more before I get to your question so
it's not really reasonable to expect
that everyone can stick it out through
the entire stream all right so let's
let's see what were you doing ok we're
setting this up so we've got our sidebar
here which is awesome and does anybody
else do this when you make something
that's interactive like this you just
click it a million times I don't know
I've done that I've had clients say that
they do that too and when they test the
site it's just like satisfying somehow
alright so that's not bad right now for
the layout let's put in a footer because
that'll be a standard layout for every
view is going to have the
have the sidebar and a footer so let's
check out what we have to work with here
with the footer do we have a footer
okay maybe maybe no maybe we don't okay
so there's a potentially maybe there's a
footer there's hope cuz there's a footer
for this site am I just missing it
with stepper I'm not used to this
terminology this is definitely different
than materialized okay that's cool
alright don't really need it for
anything right now but it's good to know
it's cool ah
okay so it looks like there's not maybe
I'm just not seeing it but looks like
there's not really a component for for a
footer I mean the closest thing I'm
seeing is bottom nav so I mean the
bottom nav would at least have the
behavior that I want of being an element
on the page that would always stay at
the bottom so maybe maybe I can try
putting this in and then just editing it
maybe I could start with this and then
edit it to look more like I would want
to footer to look like I mean really I
don't I don't absolutely need a footer
but it would make it more consistent
with all the other sites that I do for
the University if I have a standard
footer
let's see all right so let's just let's
put in the bottom half I don't really
care about having these icons right now
cuz I'm not gonna use them I just need
actually I'm not even sure if I want to
give it a death
I'm gonna see maybe this will work if I
get rid of these icons nope let's get
rid of these
let's put something in here
mm-hmm
oh there we go and you can see that all
right that's definitely not the behavior
that I want I must be missing something
let me check the chat really quick and
see
Rohan hey Rohan how's it going
you haven't really missed that much we
just got our like side navigation drawer
working basically you missed me like
making silly mistakes for about a half
an hour it looks like some we have in
the live chat some people talking about
like what they're doing with free code
camp so we have a few people working on
the tribute page and the portfolio page
and everything so that's really cool
I saw someone said the tribute page
should be so Zanna says the tribute page
should be simple yeah that's just to
give some quick advice on that you know
with those early projects and free code
camp don't worry about trying to get
them perfect right away you know just do
the make sure that you complete the user
you know stories and then move on you'll
learn a lot more and you can always come
back later and make them better how you
want and in the portfolio I'm I actually
never completed the portfolio part
because I always I always wanted a
better portfolio so I always thought
well wait and do some cool stuff and
then I'll add it in and I never went
back in and added it in at least not yet
okay all right so I don't see anyone in
the lodge chat talking about this but I
needed to maybe look at this
documentation because at least in the
materialized framework you know there
was definitely a certain structure that
you followed and it made sure that you
know the footer stayed at the bottom
even if you didn't have any content you
know things like that so I'm thinking
maybe I'm missing something
some wrapper component or something that
I should be using here so let me see if
there's like something that talks about
the layout themes those color
I guess I'll start
I guess I'm gonna check out one of the
examples and I'm also gonna look here
okay I can change the theme that's
pretty cool
okay very cool can customize the colors
and everything that's actually awesome
I'll probably end up making a standard
theme with the university colors then
and then I can just reuse that for
future projects
they're cool
all right cool so everything's in inline
style
okay I'm not definitely not gonna use
the built-in color stuff to use the
university colors okay
so didn't really find the no I didn't
actually want webpack I wanted to the
example I didn't actually find the info
I wanted within this so let's see
just wanna see how how they're doing
things
okay yeah I'm not maybe I'm missing
something y'all can fill me in I'm not
seeing anything like really special one
on there
okay
okay I see Christian said in the live
chat a footer is not part of the
material design guidelines that makes
sense
yeah make sense Sebastian I see your
your comment there it says there is no
footer in material you I but the
material I materialized CSS one is just
a grid yeah I'm not I'm not necessarily
worried about creating my own footer
component what I what I was hoping would
be kind of already made is making sure
that it stays at the bottom so I just
didn't want to have to like do that CSS
on my own if I didn't have to but it
looks like I will have to which is not
really a big deal so what all I have to
do is just make guess I make a footer
component I don't know at this point
maybe I should just move on to something
else because I don't I don't absolutely
need a footer component I just like to
have it but if I were categorizing like
what's essential to this project the
footer is definitely way down on the
list and it's not essential at all so
maybe we'll just skip over that and then
that'll give me some time to check out
how I'm doing that on my other sites
that use materialized and I'll probably
just take the mark-up materialized users
and convert that to a component and I'll
put all the Styles you know right inside
the component that's actually not a bad
idea anytime something I'm used to using
and materialize it's not here I'll just
convert that into a component and
eventually I'll end up with kind of a
hybrid set of components that that can
be used for future projects all right so
now since I'm not gonna worry about a
footer I'm gonna remove let's see the
bottom nav
and I'm gonna remove move it from here
as well and so now we have this we can
start to kind of populate how how we
want this to look let's uh let's change
some of the colors right away just to
get that out of the way so since it was
looking at this themes let's see I think
this is where I've seen it at
all right yes I definitely want to
override I'm not I'm not gonna use any
of these colors
this might be a little bit more
complicated than I thought I'd assume
that it there would be an easier way
maybe maybe there is mmmm
overthinking this so probably what I
could do then is
here instead of putting having this
variable for the color I can just change
the color
I just basically put put a hex color if
I wanted to or I could you know import
colors which may be more properly
can you only hear that in the background
yeah so my my boss came back from his
honeymoon and he has like a minion toy
so if you remember what was it was the
movie I can't remember what the movie is
now you know what I'm talk about there's
a movie with Steve Carell did the voice
for it
Despicable Me that's it so the movie
Despicable Me had minions in it and
there's like several of the movies and
then they did a separate movie for the
minions he has this little toy that's a
minion that like dances and sings so he
just got back yesterday and he's like I
keep hearing this it keeps playing it so
anyway it looks like I only have a few
seconds left on the live stream for
Instagram so you can check out the
recording if you want I don't even think
anybody's watching right now so yeah but
if you cared that noise in the
background that's what it is it's that's
that's hoyes so he even before I got the
job here he was I don't know how it
started but he had minion decorations
and stuff and occasionally would call
his workers his minions all over for fun
okay
I guess I could do this if I go in and
edit this color CAS file I'm thinking do
I really want to edit it or should I
just make another file my only hesitate
to edit things directly because what if
I want to update later on you know they
come up with a new version if I want to
just try to pull that in and update it
what I guess looking for is a way to do
like a sub theme that would remain and
still work even if I updated the main
the main theme if anybody knows how I
could do that please let me know if I
can't it's not a big deal
let's see I guess I could just look it
up
hey there we go stackoverflow has how to
do how to apply a custom theme in
material UI all right so all right so
this person on Stack Overflow wrote a
custom theme in a separate file okay
all right so it seems like I could do it
in a separate file and that would work
okay
I guess we can try that any other any
other thoughts of a better way to do
this I mean this this seems like a
similar issue to what so what we're
doing right now
okay
let's so make a separate file for now
I'm just gonna pull in
let's just pull in with this other guy
did on stackoverflow to give us
something to go by I probably won't need
to do right now I'm only worried really
about the colors so I won't need all of
it I could take probably most of it out
let's fish my
actually actually commit this first time
so if you're not familiar with git or
using the command line what I what I
just did was I checked which files I had
changed and then I committed those files
I added a message
so I actually committed and added at the
same time that's with that a.m. flag is
added a little commit message and then I
pushed those changes up to the
repository on github alright now what I
want to do is make a new component let's
say actually let's call it
let's call it that and let's pop in
whoops there we go
so let's pull this stuff in I don't need
the colors I don't think I'll need the
color manipulator I'll leave it in for
now I'm not worried about Cece and
Eric's
I'm not gonna change any of this right
now so really I'm just worried about the
palette okay so let's just try to change
the primary color for now let me pull in
all right let me show you guys the style
guide this actually I had been telling
people that I hadn't built anything in
react until like spring of this year but
I'm pretty sure that I actually built
this in December and this is my first
react project so this is in react and I
think I did use this might be next
Seana thing I think I originally tried
to do this with create react app and
then I wanted to try out next so this
might be the version they use next can
remember exactly so anyway it was not
exactly true that well it's true to say
like the first react project that
actually went live you know for a client
I did in the spring but this one was in
December of 2016 and it's not officially
live yet so it never it was supposed to
be reviewed by some people higher up and
that never really happened so it's it's
already a bit outdated I've changed some
of this but the part that I want is just
these these colors so so this is all
done with materialised framework but
basically you can see what I was trying
to do was you know kind of build out a
custom version of the materialized theme
with all the colors that we use at the
University so for now I really just I
need this dark green
and just got a message from my boss so
let me type this on my other screen back
to him so I just want to try this out
and see if it works so we'll just change
the primary color need to put that like
that so let's save that and then let's
see how how they applied it
so obviously this didn't work for them
pretty she need to have static child
context types and nothing
all right so
so I'm just trying to read over this and
trying to make sense of what was done
actually I want to see the the full code
so I miss anything so let me see
see
pretty sure they call it a themed uh
yeah a themed ojs right
all right not really sure maybe it's
been changed too much
all right let me check much time okay it
I thought I heard it beep alright so
time for a little break to go to the
live chat
so you do want a custom theme it's this
may be too much to try to fit in the
rest of the stream we'll see we'll do as
much as we can all right I'm gonna
scroll up a bit and try to catch up then
with the live Chad
all right so lot going on the live chat
but I'm not coming in upon a lot of
questions yet so I'm going to keep
scrolling and looking Vladimir asks can
you suggest some learning paths from
HTML CSS JavaScript react.js I would
recommend try the free code camp
challenges and work through that that's
that's a decent foundation to kind of
work your way up there's a lot of other
good resources as well so I think I
mentioned I did a video on my own
channel about how I became a front-end
developer and I think I mentioned some
of the resources I use there so you can
check that out the links in the
description and I'd like at some point
to do a more detailed video on that all
the resources but I think free code camp
is whilst definitely steer you in the
right direction
and so John Hanson says starting a new
project just installed webpack I'll see
where I'll go from there react look so
tempting though I still want to use pug
and sass jumping into es6 as well with
babel that's a lot of change all at once
so yeah you can still use sass with
react I know there are ways to do it I I
haven't done it but plug I don't know
does anybody use plug with with react
like would that even make sense I'm I
definitely see why it would be it would
be hard to switch if you're used to that
yeah I agree Patrick says react is not
your es6 is not hard to pick up web pack
is a pain though I agree
web package was at least for me it's
difficult I think web pack is great but
it's just difficult you know if you if
you're not used to it it's really like a
steep learning curve
Dixie says nervous about making my
tribute page any tips on how to not look
at the source code and trusting my
knowledge yeah I mean I guess you just
got to resist that temptation to look at
the source code and I would say don't
the tribute page is a really really
basic type of thing so you know work
through don't don't get really nervous
thinking it has to be perfect or
everything just worry about meeting
those user stories those requirements
just the basics and then once you met
those you know like hey like you've
completed the project and then anything
else you do on top of that is great but
at least you got to that point where
it's complete and I had a similar thing
happen earlier so on my lunch break I
was doing some work on my react course
and the first project I had gotten to
the point where I had fulfilled all the
requirements but I didn't really do a
lot of customizations and I thought
about it and I really wanted to do
customizations but I thought you know
what I fulfilled it like I need to just
turn this in and move on and learn more
instead of worrying about trying to make
it you know really really good and
perfect so that's what I did so I just
turned it in and it would be really cool
if I had made it unique but you only
only have so much time you know it was
better you know to move on and continue
learning than to wait and wait and get
backed up and maybe never get to some of
the later stuff in the course all right
let me do scroll through a bit more NDM
says how did you start learning react
hey Andy and he also has a YouTube
channel where he does live streams so
you can check that out how did I start
I think I started with just reading over
the react documentation trying to get a
hold of that and then I I did the course
from code Academy and watched a bunch of
YouTube videos that was like my very
beginning and create react app then came
out after so I think I had started
trying to learn it before that came out
when that came out it was cool when it
was really helpful and then when next
j/s started to get so when next Jess
first started out it wasn't a lot of the
features they have now they didn't have
so it was okay but not nearly as good as
it is now so as they added features then
it started getting really fun to work
with with next
okay
Galaxy Tab asks when building react
project using Mac what software do I use
yeah you just need a code editor I mean
really I mean you need note okay it
looks like Patrick Patrick answer it
says whatever editor you want you also
need node and NPM so that's cool
galaxy says you don't need Xcode or
Visual Studio yeah you don't need any of
that
alright I'm almost at the bottom Elijah
that's why I'm kind of going everytime a
little bit cuz it's just so tempting to
get to the bottom John says John Samoa
we have several John's that are in here
so I have to start using the full name
but Johnson Buddha says Jessie you rock
more commits all sub slash viewers
should submit pull requests and help him
out that he can review offline oh well
thanks for saying that that's cool
yeah I totally don't expect you all to
you know help help out so um I'll do
this no matter what as long as I think
it's helpful to you but yeah if you if
you have if you have the time and you
want to work on it and submit some pull
requests um that's awesome of course
like I can't guarantee that every pull
request is going to make it in sometimes
there are really good things that don't
make it in just because I don't have
time have to move on so it's not even
necessarily because like I didn't like
what you've done I might really like it
and just don't have time to pull it in
but yeah if anyway I appreciate you
saying that
okay all right so I'm pretty much to the
bottom of the chat right now I'll come
back to it in a bit all right
so let's go this will probably be my
last see what time it is yeah this will
be my last Pomodoro session before we do
questions and so I want to try to be
done around for today is I think I
mentioned it yesterday
maybe I didn't all right I don't think I
mention it so today is my wife's
birthday and my my son's birthday so
they they share a birthday so I want to
get home at a decent time so that I can
celebrate their birthday and then
tomorrow is my other son's birthday so
we've got like you know birthday weekend
happening here all right so what were we
working on we're trying to apply this
theme right yes all right so I'm gonna
move this over to my other screen for a
second and I'm gonna come back here and
look at I want to look at the actual
documentation and compare it to what the
this person was going on stackoverflow
so this is asked by nose not much on
Sakura flow
okay that's good to know I didn't see
that before it says never directly and
you take the theme
okay cool this this looks like I can do
is just some basic manipulation of the
theme just to try it out at first like
this okay that works I don't know why
but when I read this before it didn't
make sense to me but then after after
looking at again now it makes sense I
guess that's out is it happens
frequently maybe my my brain just needed
to work on that subconsciously while I
was doing other things to get it so so
I'll probably end up putting some stuff
in a separate file at first so I'm not
going to delete this or anything I'll
just leave it for now but I think really
what I need to do is where I have is
this theme provider I can add in this
copy and paste this
and
and let me take that that color where
did I have that that primary color
I figured that was to take the whole
thing primary cover
okay
now let's see what that does oops is not
defined no undefined
all right what am I doing wrong
this is not fun uh maybe I did I'm not I
didn't put this in
cool check it out all right so our
primary color which I suspected the
primary color changed the title bark is
that that made sense so I did cool and I
think it shrunk did that are tired boy
get smaller or at this calling app bar
so material UI closes the app bar cool
alright so now potentially if I want to
I could use a separate file if I end up
customizing a lot or if I don't I could
I could just leave this in here if I'm
only gonna customize a few things cool
it's nice when things work oh cool I see
if a lot of you saying happy birthday
for my wife and both of my son's
birthdays so thanks I'll let them know
that you all said happy birthday
sometimes like all my kids I'll say like
occasionally if you all tell me to like
tell my family or my kids something I'll
say like everybody on YouTube said this
and they kind of look at me like what's
weird look
the oh no I'm sorry I just got
distracted I so I did the video on
Instagram and I waited way too long to
hit the share button and so now I
couldn't share it so that's too bad I'll
have to remember next time
Tana looks like my wife posted a video
on Instagram of my son Ambrose blowing
out candles on a cupcake that's cool now
now I wish I was home
all right so let's so ace we have the
color we can change our theme
what's our secondary color gonna be
probably the gold it's it's gonna be the
gold or do we go think actually I might
go with where so that the style guide I
might go with this yellow
I'm gonna see how this primary primary
color - okay now okay I think I want the
yellow to be the accent color primary
color - maybe it'll be cold
it probably won't really make any sense
to change these yet because I don't have
any elements on the page where I could
see what it would do so I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna do anything more with this
until we build this out a little bit
more actually what we'll probably do is
we might not even have this title or
this app bar be green I know it's like
not exactly in line with the material
design specs but I've been doing this a
little bit differently lately where I
have a white app bar with a thin gold
border underneath and then we have a
logo that's that uses the green and the
gold colors that shows up nicely on the
white so I might end up one with that
too because my boss really likes that it
looks nice it looks very nice it's clean
so that might change but for now at
least if we figured out how to change
the theme colors so what we need now is
to figure out our our basic layout let
me see how much time I have left okay 15
minutes all right so we need to figure
out kind of like the basic layout that
we're going to use and in case you you
either didn't see or don't remember I'll
bring over what we're going from
and where did I put that I don't know
where I put that so I'll just type it
again all right so here's what here's
what it currently looks like and I'm not
gonna try to mimic this exactly
but basically I need what I need is for
users to be able to get to any section
of this site immediately when the page
loads so I don't want a long scrolling
page so that's pretty much the only
requirement for the the first screen
that users see so I mean this works I
could try to just mimic this what do
y'all think let me know let me know what
you think about maybe keeping this
there's something similar
okay so Patrick says plus one for the
current layout yeah I my initial thought
yesterday was to like change it but now
that I look at it it's not I mean it
works it's I don't really know what I
would do that would be better to direct
users to the different parts of the site
okay cool looks I guess and get some
more votes
Rud Rud rank rank Shu Nandi sorry if I
mess up the pronunciation for your name
says make something out of the box I I
would love to make something out of the
box but I do have to keep the users in
mind and in this case my users it's
probably good to go over the who the
users are for this with you all cuz I
don't think I've done this yet my users
are this is going to be an internal site
for university employees and that
includes a lot of people who are older
professors who don't really use
technology very much at all so I mean
we're talking about like people like
they don't have smartphones they want
everything printed out there so I have
to keep that user basin in mind so I
mean there's the majority of people or
like somewhat ok with using computers
but there's definitely a group on campus
that it needs to be very very
straightforward so with that in mind
then we you know we'll go forward with
this so it seems like let's let's just
try to keep this layout so basically we
just need columns we need three column
layout two rows how to I don't even
remember how this looks ok so then it
just goes yeah so we just need to set up
two break points and I have no idea how
the break points and the grid system
works in material UI so let's check that
out
is that okay
grid okay cool
so I guess this is similar to what I
need
so say this is a grid list I'm wondering
is there a layout something more than
I'm missing here
so it wouldn't even it wouldn't
necessarily be a component I don't know
yeah I don't think the grid list is what
I'm really looking for I'm wondering now
this material UI then does it not come
with a like a system of columns
actually if if it is the case that it
doesn't come with a system of columns
I'm wondering if I can just pull out
then the whole black column system from
materialise and use it use it here
all right
okay Christian said I might have to new
use the newer version I'm buried this is
an enumerative also we're back to this
so it yesterday I originally had this
version installed and then I switched
and installed the new version and then I
was advised to not use the new version
since it wasn't really ready yet and so
I switched it back to the old version
I let me I'm not I don't think I'm gonna
switch over but I just want to see it I
wanna see what it's like it
yeah this actually is exactly what I
want I don't know I don't know everyone
I really kind of want to switch now
yeah
all right now and now everybody's saying
switch Maxie me I don't think I can't
use get get revert of revert anyway I
changed too many things I think yeah I'm
like I might switch back let me check
really quick because I know you all told
me yesterday that there were some
components that I couldn't use because
they weren't ready with this one man I
just like how close is this to being
done like are we talking like a year
until it's released or I can't I really
want to I don't want to know
I didn't see anything talking about a
time line
all right let's see what components who
we are all right we have the app bar
right that's that standard let's see
what an e be a bar for sure I don't care
about the bottom nerve right now
I'll need cards which that should like
that standard
I need form elements let's see what the
form that that might be the deal breaker
so we have text fields where's my okay
cool I like using the ones where the
label pops out all right awesome so we
got a text fields we need select with a
Canadian column select they were
dropdowns right do we not have dropdowns
okay here's some checkboxes it's good
actually I'm not I don't really like
that as much as the way materialized
doesn't I might have to modify that
component because I really like the way
materialized of it
cool all right I'll I I do like that
switches
okay so menus so basically text field
select menus coming soon all right so
they don't have that this should work
though for what I needed to do just like
a regular menu as long as I can just get
the value of whatever is clicked on
which shouldn't be a problem then all
right cool
um I think that this version actually
does have everything that I need so
maybe we'll go with it
all right I know it looks like some of
the people that were really against me
using the the latest version of this are
not here right now so so they're not
here to tell me not to do it Oh
Maxie man I know I know it was a joke
about the river it was just I was just
reading it out
ok Johnson muta says you know you'll be
upgrading later might as well do it now
Christian says feels pretty stable
finished to me smack says I always
wondered how long it takes to make a
legit web app by yourself it's I suppose
it takes a long time if you keep
switching your your framework back and
forth every day okay John smoother says
it could fork it KB and says look at the
roadmap oh okay cool am I missing the
roadmap then what is that
oh this has support for some CSS and J's
that's cool I like that better than
having to do all inline stuff so it's
another plus
okay Kevin as linked ok so there's some
issues check out the github
okay cool this is super helpful thank
you thank you for this link also my
timer went off so the the rest of this
is until I'd like to end around 4
o'clock so I'll try to get as many
questions answered as I can and if I
don't get to your question just send it
to me on Twitter or put it in the
comments below if you were just here for
the code thank you so much for watching
and for for helping me out and I'll be
back next week alright so let me look
just quickly at this hmm this is as of
all right so this was edited six months
ago so I assume it's better now
yes it looks like maybe this list is not
maybe it's not up to date
is there's a new section now in the docs
let's see
all right let's check the docks then
I said they added it but I don't
remember seeing that oh yeah there it is
haha I can't believe I miss that
cool
to say don't support multi-line text
fields it can't be that hard to apply
the same styles to a multi-line text
field as you can to a single line so
assuming this list is up-to-date this is
probably one that might be able to do a
pull request for and get that updated
okay let me go to the live chat now I'm
gonna scroll up a bit and try to answer
as many questions as I can right now I'm
thinking that I'm I'm gonna switch and
if they don't have something that we
need we will add it and potentially
submit a pull request and contribute to
this project so like I mentioned
yesterday I've actually been wanting to
either do something like this on my own
or contribute to one so I think I found
a decent one to contribute to okay
Sorrenti so sss r NT y s is react hard I
don't know I think something being hard
or not is really relative questions so
react doesn't seem that hard to me now
but when I first started it did seem
really hard so I mean just like anything
you know practice at it and keep at it
and you'll be I mean a year ago I was
just hearing about react you know now
I'm able to actually build things with
react at work so you know in less than a
year you can get to a point where you
could you could be getting paid to make
react stuff
let's see Christian as you mentioned
earlier the discount at udacity would
you recommend it to learn react where
would you place it in relation to free
code camp okay that's actually a really
good question so for me this is how I've
used free code camp and Udacity so this
is going to be pretty specific to me but
there might be some other people in
similar position than I am
so free code camp is really easy to just
go in and do really quick things
especially like in the browser just go
in and do the exercises and spend like a
few minutes a day just doing something
just to you know just to keep things
fresh in your mind so for me I used it
like that that's where I would come in
like before I started work I would do
one challenge from free code camp now
there are like projects that you can't
just do in a couple minutes but a lot of
the challenges you could finish in a few
minutes
so that's how I would use it and just do
it just a little bit every day for
Udacity it's it's set up as these large
courses a lot of them are free which is
really cool
but I was less able to just do things so
some of the courses do have in browser
exercises but a lot of them require you
to set up your development environment
so those were more like if I had a an
hour to work on something then I could
do that so and and those were also
sometimes really specific to something
that I wanted to learn you know so
they're broken up into these courses so
if I really wanted to focus on one thing
I could do that and be done with that
course free code campus is more like
just a linear progression all the way
through it's a little bit harder to just
pick and choose things because it builds
so anyway so I use them both at the same
time and it was simply a matter of
I tried to do a little bit from free
code camp every day and if I had a few
minutes it was free code camp if I had
some specific topic that I really wanted
to go like in more depth with I would
use Udacity and I would have to set
aside more time to do it the majority of
what I've done from Udacity has been all
their free stuff this react course that
I'm taking now is the first time I've
actually paid for they call them nano
degrees from Udacity so so far I've been
happy with it but there's more than
enough free content on Udacity that you
could learn a lot without paying for
anything so hopefully that helps
hopefully answer your question
okay Johnson mood has had just made it
over from another live coding session at
treehouse cool I didn't realize
treehouse had live coding I'll have to
often check that out is the treehouse
live coding is it free or is it
something that you have to pay for so I
know some of their stuff is paid and
they do offer some free things John also
said thank you for the live work you're
welcome thanks for watching
adventurous programmers said I use
Stephen Ritter's webpack course on udemy
for ten dollars to learn web pack to
made it easy that's really good to know
thanks for sharing that so if anybody's
trying to learn web pack check out udemy
Stephen Stephen graders web pack course
so yeah again thanks for that
okay ooh brain shoo Nandi says you he
provided a link to where you could use
pug with react so it's if there's a
babble plug-in to use plug with react so
if you check out the the pug repo on
github it looks like it's in there so
thanks for sharing that that battery con
says I am just I'm just a beginner but
my friend said JavaScript is very
complex and hard to learn is this true I
don't I don't know if it's I don't
really think JavaScript is that complex
and hard to learn but you know i've i've
been using javascript for years so it's
i guess it's hard to remember what it
was like at the beginning learning so I
would say like if you're thinking about
learning it go for it you know there's
you're not really risking anything by
trying it you'll find out soon whether
or not you think it's too complicated
but I mean I I don't think like a lot of
people learn it you know you know
average people of average intelligence
learn it so I don't think it's you know
that difficult
John says John Hanson says it's odd to
see you code react here as pug as much
of the same sort of thing as component
building they're just the HTML it uses
JavaScript feels very logical to me the
reactant yeah yeah definitely reactives
does remind me a bit of different like
templating different ways to do
templating so yeah it shouldn't it
shouldn't be that much of a jump to move
to react from something else like pug or
I guess even you can think of like
handlebars or something like that hey
Jordan how's it going Jordan said hi
okay so Patrick said earlier let me put
this up on the screen
Patrick really dislikes that I was doing
this in index J s and thought I should
be doing it an app j s so okay so that's
cool I mean that will not be a problem
to move that over so I mean I'm not
gonna do it right now but basically you
know she lets you know what I would do
it'd be as simple as removing kind of
this out of here and then wrapping it
wrapping app in this so it would have
the same the same effect I'm assuming I
don't see any reason why it wouldn't
work
Kevin asked this register serviceworker
come with create react app yes it did I
didn't add that in that came by default
Zanna said I don't quite get it what is
supposed to be that white space under
there so yeah I think I assumed you were
talking about this all this white space
yeah that was probably just I had the
idea that I wanted this overlap up here
so yeah it's always gonna have this
white space probably what I'll end up
doing is vertically centering this if I
redo it because I'm not gonna have this
giant header so everything would be
vertically centered so there would still
be a lot of white space but it would be
at least evenly distributed okay cool
and I just read Roe on your comment
about moving the grid towards the bottom
and so yeah that's exactly what I intend
to do
Zanna says I suggest you make an
accessibility audit yeah that's that's
actually a good idea
I'm actually really conscious of helping
people who are blind or have vision
impairments being able to go through the
site so we do have one professor who's
blind and so I want to make sure that
she can in all the sites that I do I
really do want to make sure that she can
you know see it be able to use a screen
reader for everything so when I
initially made this I'm not sure that I
I kept that in mind as much as I should
but I definitely want to this time so
I'm gonna have to look up some more with
it as well because I'm sure there's some
stuff that I could be doing that I'm not
also I have an uncle that's blind so I'm
always like what I'm doing sites I'm
always thinking like would he even be
able to use this site so
so thanks for bringing that up s-- and i
definitely it's definitely something i
want to keep in mind as I'm building it
I'm just reading all the messages that
you all had about me switching to the
newer version of material UI so it seems
like the messages now are just excited
for going for it as they were yesterday
about not going for it I mean to be fair
there are different people in here today
a lot of different people than there
were yesterday so so it's not like
everybody's changing them I'm changing
my mind but not I don't know that you
all are changing master mine says hello
sir what's HTML Java JavaScript and CSS
alright that's that's like a really big
question let me try to give a very like
succinct answer so I'm not going to talk
about Java Java is a programming
language computer programming language
that I'm not very familiar with so I'm
gonna leave that out now but things like
Android apps are built with Java but as
far as HTML Javascript and CSS those are
the languages that websites are built
from so the HTML would be gives the
structure to the page the javascript
helps with interactivity so things
moving around on the page data being
sent to different places and then the
CSS is the style of the page you know
the colors the fonts things like that so
I guess as an analogy if you were
building a house the HTML would be the
frame of the house the CSS would be all
the decorations and then the JavaScript
would be like all the electricity
running through the house and the
plumbing that makes the water flow and
the lights turn on
and you know things like that not really
a perfect analogy but I think it works
well enough
oh cool Christian says I had mentioned
earlier based on the documentation I was
looking at that they didn't support
multi-line text fields but Christian
says they do support it and Christian is
using those multi-line text fields so
good to know so evidently that
documentation is not updated so I'll
just have to see for myself and you know
what's available what's not and not rely
on that documentation
okay Patrick says has pasted in some
content from the material UI roadmap
okay there's the Reb map dot M D off to
check out that file later but it says
first both versions can be used at the
same time people can progressively
migrate one component at a time that's
really cool okay that's something I'll
have to think about maybe I don't have
to completely switch maybe I can just
pull in some of the components that I
need so that's really cool that must
mean that they're actually really
compatible if you can just pull in a
component when you need it that's good
to know
Christian asks what will the back end be
for your application I guess in it like
in terms of like the back end it's just
going to be I'm not exactly sure what
you're asking so I'll just give you a
basic idea of like the whole stack so I
mean I'm gonna run it obviously with
node and Express and then the data
there's not I'm not really dealing with
a lot of data so I'm gonna send data to
a project management system called Reich
and then I'm gonna email it out
as well I haven't decided yet if I'm
actually gonna try to save data in a
database it might be cool to do that so
it may depending on how long this takes
I may have time to try to do something
like that but I'm not super familiar
with how to set up databases so so
anyway that's it's it's not going to be
really complex a complex site
okay cool Patrick says I was always on
Team go for it awesome this is I think
the last comment so this would be the
last question that I am that I answer
for today and it's from pear cake so
pear cake says hi Jessie can you give an
advice where I can find good app specs
that I can read and implement in a
fairly big react app I'm not very good
at imagining apps for practice hmm I
don't know
so I'm guessing let me know if I'm wrong
on this but base like you're asking for
ideas for large apps that you can make I
know I don't know what the websites are
it's been so long since I've been on
them but I know there are some sites
that just give a ton of ideas for for
apps so people just you know offer their
ideas and you can you can work on them
so try to look up something like that
I just I'm sorry I just I can't remember
at all with the name of the these even
even one of those sites were and I'm
pretty sure there's several different
ones so I would check out something like
that otherwise like you could you know
try asking colleagues or you know
friends family for their ideas about
things so I'm somewhat similar situation
that I don't I don't exactly have a lot
of ideas on my own it's hard to come up
with them alright okay cool christian
said ideas watch.com slash start-up
ideas slash app so cool Thank You
Christian
alright so patrick says go celebrate
with your family so and he says thanks
for stream you welcome and i'm
definitely going to do that right now so
thank you all so much for watching and
for all of your help it's
day and didn't get a lot done in terms
of what's on the screen but I think we I
have a much better understanding of
material UI so I think it was it was a
good day for learning so yeah so Co on
Monday and have a great weekend